statements by their excellencies prime
ministers of
ukraine
we are bringing here full support for
your future
not only
european path but eu membership
i i think that
as i said before
if you're looking across europe now we
don't see any other country which is
fighting for european values more than
ukrainian
ukrainian people are doing uh currently
so we are also here to tell you that
you're not alone your fight is our fight
and together we will prevail ukrainian
you are fighting for
your lives your freedom but we know that
you are also fighting for our lives and
and our freedom and it's
for us very
important and uh
i said also the first briefing that
probably
the main goal of our visit and the main
message of our our mission is to say to
our ukrainian friends that they are not
alone that europe stand with
with you our countries stand with you
and it's something which
i think it's it's in these days in this
difficult day is very important we have
been providing humanitarian aid
we have been also providing you with
some military supplies that
you can better defend yourself
we admire your courage and
we will continue to provide more aid
and support and let me say
slava ukraine